Joe is with us to start off this hour in
San Jose hi Joe how are you hey mr.
Ramsey thanks for taking my call today
sure how can I help my question was
wrong I got referred to you from a
friend of mine and I got myself in a
pickle here
I said drive for uber in 2015
didn't drive too much because I passed
control and so I was kind of doing on
and off I think I made about 3 grams in
that year doing work and the IRS sent
means eleven thousand dollar bill in the
mail saying that I owe them that by
August 16 I looked at it and they gave
me options like a payment plan
installments and I didn't call yet how
do you end up owing $11,000 on three
thousand dollars worth of income well I
guess what happened was whoever sent out
a notification the email back then and
2015 saying that if we didn't make over
six thousand dollars reading the file so
me thinking they're a corporation know
what they're talking about other okay
you know I don't have to follow that you
know what I made which obviously was a
huge mistake
no yeah there's no way that there's no
way taxes on three thousand dollars in
2015 becomes an eleven thousand dollar
bill some way I said yeah there's a
mistake of some kind a huge one yeah
this should be a thousand though and
that would be a thousand dollars not
eleven thousand dollars okay yeah I got
it I gotta take a look at that a little
deeper because it's referring and I'm
looking at the IRS thing and it's
talking about what I made with with uber
and so I'm just kind of puzzled how many
years did you drive for uber well I
drove in two thousand for about two two
and a half years with them okay Animoto
long do that to an M years would you
make oh man
over in two years I want to say about
maybe 120 with them $120,000 yeah yeah
in the year because you made a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars driving for
uber in two years yeah combined
I'm so confused I thought you told me
you made three thousand dollars the
third year in 2015 that's when I switch
in a transition from uber to pest
control during that transition oh I see
but the other two years you made sixty
grand a year yeah yeah so that you pay
taxes you pay taxes in those two years
yeah I filed for those two years yes and
paid the taxes yes correct okay there if
the only income that has not had tax
paid on it is three thousand dollars
eleven thousand dollars is not possible
so there's a mistake but I'm thinking
it's more complicated than that
like maybe you miss filed on the other
two years so here's what you're going to
do all right jump online of Dave Ramsey
comm and click on ELP for endorsed local
provider for tax help and it will
finally give you someone in your area
that we recommend for tax help you
desperately need a tax pro just sit down
and take them take them your old tax
returns that you filed for those other
years and the year that you didn't file
take them your receipts from uber and
sit down and then take this IRS notice
and they'll be able to weed through and
figure this out okay so here there's one
of two possible things that will happen
when they do all of that
number one they could find a huge
mistake that the IRS has made which is
what I think has occurred based on what
you're telling me I can't tell for sure
which means that you don't know anywhere
near eleven thousand dollars and that
would be a huge relief right now but
let's say the worst thing that possible
could happen would be that they go
through this and they go okay when you
properly file you're going to owe this
eleven thousand dollars because of this
this and this all right so you got a 11
does not a problem just like you called
me with and that's your worst case
scenario
well what are you making a year now why
now doing pest control about sixty five
year okay you have any money saved
I have no nothing saved nothing save
that no okay do you have any other debt
yeah I had a hunch you'd ask that so my
total debt is 33 grand all I want are
payment a car payment one car
repo and a couple medical things and one
credit card how old are you 25 I'm 29 29
okay
mom okay so the answer to your IRS
question is this if you get the $11,000
bill after you've had it all checked out
and that's really what it is you can put
that on an installment plan which is
what they're offering you and then I
want you to put it at the top of your
debt snowball which is where you list
all of your debts smallest to largest to
start cleaning up your debts it's the
very first one I want you to clean up
because the IRS is all-powerful and
they're ridiculous interest rates and
fees that are going to be adding on all
the time until you get rid of them so
they're the first thing you want to get
rid of when you have the chance and
you're going to you're going to pay like
two three thousand bucks a month and
it's going to be gone before Christmas
that and then you're going to move on to
your other debts now having told you
that there's a bunch of stuff going on
in this conversation that says that it's
time for you to get control of your
money right car repo in your past
improper filings on taxes in your past
debt in your future and in your past if
you don't do something about it and so
all of these things are saying it's time
for you to use all this hard work you're
doing more to your benefit and that's by
getting control of your money so you
need to get on a money plan with us and
we'll walk you through this like get on
a budget to start working these baby
steps start doing the things you hear us
talk about here on the air it's time for
you to do that there's a lot of symptoms
going on in your life it's time for you
to address all of those things but your
first thing you do is you open up the
computer right now you're going Dave
Ramsey calm you click ELP for
NORs local provider for a tax
professional in your area because do you
need some professional tax advice
someone to comb through the tangles in
this hair and get this thing figured out
because you may not owe anything or you
may owe just a very very small amount
that's possible as well hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]